this is almost out of a movie
one of the main people behind this now
national school policy to hide gender
transitions of little kids from parents
was the bald-headed lipstick wearing
stiletto having luggage stealing nuclear
waste official from the Biden
Administration Sam Brinton who If This
Were a cartoon If This Were a comic book
which increasingly our country seems to
be this guy would be one of the big
super villains
he looks like it he acts like it and
this guy was behind the policy that now
instructs schools to keep this sexual
grooming from parents because before Sam
Brinton worked in the Biden
Administration he worked for a terrible
group called The Trevor Project
now the Trevor Project seems like it has
a really good Mission the Trevor Project
part of its Mission it says is to
prevent LGBT youths from killing
themselves so that's that's a worthwhile
Endeavor we don't want LGBT youths or
any other youths to kill themselves and
so that's a great thing but in practice
that's not what the Trevor Project does
in practice what the Trevor Project does
is works over time to indoctrinate kids
into
radical LGBT ideology Works to promote
transgenderism for every younger groups
of people we're talking about major
mutilations uh disfigurements that will
last a whole lifetime that could
sterilize kids all it does is work to do
all it works to do rather is to double
down on this crazy ideology and so when
Brenton was working for the Trevor
Project in 2019
he was directing advocacy and government
Affairs there he helped create a model
for school district policy for suicide
prevention
and the model has been adopted at least
partially by State education departments
in Arizona Idaho as well as local school
districts in California New Hampshire
Oregon other States including Washington
and New Jersey have similar policies and
and the the
model is don't tell parents when their
kids start getting into the weird sex
stuff
that's the model
and it's hard even to talk about it
because they say well we're doing this
to prevent suicides and it reminds me of
every abusive relationship you've ever
heard of
and man woman doesn't matter every
abusive relationship when it gets really
really bad they say if you don't do
exactly what I want I'm gonna kill
myself
and and it's this kind of emotional
blackmail and exploitation and
manipulation where even that people made
of the toughest stuff will very often
give in he says well I don't I don't
want that to happen and what the Trevor
Project does here what Sam Brinton does
here is even worse is they're saying if
you don't give us exactly what we want
your kid is going to kill himself
and what do we want we want you to pump
your kid full of hormones put your kid
on puberty blockers eventually chop off
your kids genitals and pretend that your
little son is actually your little
daughter or your little daughter is
actually your little son and if you
don't do that your kid is going to kill
himself that's what they're saying evil
evil stuff and not true by the way not
backed up by any evidence whatsoever
no evidence that the gender transition
in the various mutilations that go along
with it actually reduce suicide rates
among people who suffer this sexual and
gender confusion zero evidence there's a
lot of evidence that people come to
regret their transitions even though the
number of people who have ever gone
through these procedures is
extraordinarily small it's growing very
quickly and so now we're finally
starting to see the first round of
people who are beginning to regret this
and they're coming out they're saying
I've destroyed my body I've ruined my
voice I've ruined my hair I'm sterile
how on Earth could adults have allowed a
14 year old to do this sort of thing
we're finally hearing that the Trevor
Project Sam Brenton these school
districts in Indiana and Maine and all
over the country they say no forget
about that ignore that if you don't
engage in
the radical insane ideology to mutilate
and castrate your kids while they are
just going to kill themselves and you're
gonna have that blood on your hands can
you imagine
why does Sam Brinton care so much about
your kids why do all these people
they're all the same they're all you
know there are all these weirdo guidance
counselors like the guy up in May in the
26 year I think he's a guy who knows he
goes by Sam which I guess is gender
ambiguous
but who knows I guess he presents as a
guy so let's call him a guy
why is he so interested in a 13 year old
girl and psychosexually grooming her why
is Sam Brent I think a large part of the
reason why these people are so focused
on your kids and driving a wedge between
you and your kids and perverting the
mind and body of your kids is in is in
large part because they don't have kids
themselves
I'm not saying they would abuse their
children or sexually abuse their
children or anything like that I'm
saying
when people have children they raise
their children in the way that they want
them to be raised if you're a Christian
family you're going to raise your kids
to be Christian if you're a Jewish
Family you're going to raise your kids
to be Jewish if you're a weird lib
you're going to raise your kids you're
going to at least try to raise your kids
to be a weird lib
but these people don't have kids and so
I think they're I strongly suspect
they're natural longings to form the
next generation are just being projected
onto your kids where there is so much
less accountability where they are so
much more willing to engage in radical
kind of behaviors because they won't
have to deal with any of the
consequences the rest of the show
continues now uh today is not music
Monday but we're making it music Monday
because you know I'm a pop Maven we're I
was on the road yesterday it was a
little tricky to do the member block so
uh Ben Davies says that I am now going
to complete the pop music Trifecta we
have done T Swift
we've done the Biebs now we are moving
on to Ed Sheeran if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
oh
foreign